sei mio ribelli forse oggi riusciamo a
fare un gioco che non mi fa incazzare
spero per prima cosa impara le basi ciò
che alla fine integro per accelerare va
bene io non devo capire un attimo una
roba io sto bene a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti questo nuovo video se non
potevo farla in trovano ma l'hanno fatta
fare perché sono successe come al solito
delle cose siamo sul gioco tipici grande
scender l'ho scaricato perché sembra
decisamente figo per scambiare in un
modo che veramente può accompagnare solo
guardali roma donna nel tutorial e meno
male che un tutorial che non l'ho fatto
davvero se non finivo malissimo supera
il traguardo quindi se fai se bordelli
nel tutorial che cosa fai nelle partite
normali esclude ora dichiarò pa porca
vacca che sfiga
guardali mamma mia mamma mia che
giocatore è
del lavoro e ora di provare quel che
farei a fare quel che derapata della
parte lui la madonna
porca vacca che figata l'ha fatto
benissimo sto gioco si lamentava un già
l'ho pagato 20 euro quindi non poteva
fare schifo e giù per abbassarmi poi su
per saltare non ho ben capito spero di
averlo fatto però ok bene a chi genera
di livelli dal caso oggetti genera
livelli tipo minecraft ma dava il gioco
della vita se te le genera a caso il
gioco della vita c'è ciao nei ragazzi
oggi fa vigeva insegna come andare in
bici perché voi non lo sapete fare io si
trova ora va come cadere sopra un sasso
c'era quello sei caduto sta e grazie che
me l'hai detto meno male se non l'avrei
mai capito
vai vai vai vai vai frate vai fronte
guardalo li guarda lì sempre questa mi
piego amo i sassi c'è qualche problema
siete sassofoni perché non lo sono
nel caso non si fosse capito magari mi
chiamo quel sasso che dici ma tra tutte
le cose che poteva generare il livello
proprio un sassolino a mettere un bravo
mamma mia ma quella che ci sono i check
point in sto gioco cosa guardali questo
c'è spero sia un check point raga perché
sono un casino doppio
e vabbè vabbè cose accadono va bene
poi c'è la musica che mi casa un botto
c'era gava neanche geometri dacie così
figo ecco questo mi sembra più un
bordello gli spettacoli prima ma
proviamoci uguale vai quanto mi casa sto
gioco
quanto sono gasato quanto son caduto
però ne è valsa la pena il backflip al
suo fascino e ragga c'è il back livello
preferisco di brutto non so perché cioè
rispetto al fronte di fa qualcosa in più
non so cosa le bocce più grosse
probabilmente vadano guarda lo guarda lo
guarda lo sa o poveri ciao poveri con la
graziella io sono pmi xbench madonna che
salta brutto leva pec dove sto andando
fratel traguardo dall'altra parte voglio
vedere il replay
vi prego
[Musica]
poi c'è
non vedo cadere tutto scemo hai vinto va
bene
bellissimo va bene allora ho provato con
la ripidità al massimo esegui atterraggi
puliti va bene c'è c'è la modalità
storia di sta roba almeno si ma avete
tutte canzoni e dm così mi volete fare
innamorare proprio eseguì un atterraggio
puliti va bene
addirittura c'è una che canta questo è
un atterraggio pulito mi sembra di stare
su spotify solo che non siamo su spotify
atterraggio unito
dai che tra un po parte il drop o questa
è la politica cioè più pulito di questo
ci sono mastrolindo a drop lancio ma cio
gela scopo non vedo dove sto andando
però ok va bene
iolo gioco della vita reja
spero che noi mettono il copy l'ex sta
roba cos'è quella roba lì fai un 3 62
volte fai una giravolta falla un'altra
volta va bene
362 volte in che senso da 60 così
qualcosa mi dice che non era così però
aveva fatto io posso andare più di testa
proprio oltre 60 non è questo vento 60
quando giri intorno porca vacca e gli
alberi occhio ho fatto a due volte
giustamente ma due volte nel senso che
devo farlo due in una botta sola o va
bene i due staccate due staccate fatto
che bello ragazzi ciclista number one
nel mondo
ecco stavo scherzando 22 euro ben spesi
santo iddio qua devo fare due backflip
la band betclic sono easy in teoria
teoria omega ad c'è c'è non lo so cioè
se avete bisogno di qualcuno che vi
faccia riferisca videogiochi chiamatemi
arrivo io dò mai la il sasso
ecco infatti mandato tutta [ __ ]
perché sono morto cos'era wire bari back
flip beige nets baby let's go bene raga
ne mancano due e ho fatto finisci meno
di 35 secondi a me questo e in meno di
35 secondi va bene sono a tagliare tutto
tagliatutto tagliatutto tagliatutto
taglia tutto qua sto facendo castro
vedendo devi fare è veloce non i font
l'ip vai vai vai zio
vabbè già che c'ero sì però è un
problema di secondi che circondi 555
occhio occhio
secondo me mi sono fratturato qualcosa
non so bene cosa però mi sono fratturato
ma non prenderle rampe scusa se devi
finire in 35 secondi vai diretto al
traguardo scusa così taglio tutto
proprio anche la famiglia passa in mezzo
alla porta a porta
la vedo però ci sono passato in mezzo
alla porta 15
non so dove il traguardo ragazzone in
mezzo alle colline di heidi eccolo
madonna quanto sta andando
guardalo fenomeno no no no no no del
traguardo sala in sala ed è tanto ormai
tranquillo perfetto a fare la spesa
bravo così boss level salve perché c'è
una palla di fieno che mi sta smontando
il circuito sapete voi sopravvivi al
salto finale la madonna è quella la
sfida c'è l'unica sfida di questo
livello e sopravvivere assalto finale
per cosa c'è assalto finale di così
strano scusatemi che salto che sa lui la
madonna il treno harry potter
questo è il salto finale
[Musica]
mi sa che ci ho creduto troppo ai vari
mezzi a due e tre
questo come come perché sono morto a
perché devo credere no sono stato
promossa quindi non me l'ha fatto fare
se va beh sì ma ho capito tutto di
quello che è successo te lo giuro ma a
malapena capisco il percorso secondo te
capisco ma figura no era è andato a culo
della sicura impossibile come fai a
capire quando stai toccando il suono non
lo senti mai nella vita
ciao ho fatto due salti ma va bene così
ok aveva dato buono chissenefrega asse
completi l'obiettivo tira una vita solo
quello ma altri tasti che non conoscevo
sono successe cose non fatte domande
grazie
scusate ma come dovrei atterrare quando
faccio salti della madonna perché non
l'ho capita sta roba
cioè quando fa i salti enormi non puoi
atterrare ceti sfracelli come niente
lega va bene con che fisica a un
atterraggio pulito in faccia
beh questo questo era pulito ma scusate
ma se io vado fuori dalla mappa che
succede 80 km in bici morto
[Musica]
c'è qualcosa che non mi quadra in tutto
questo ma non facciamo domande va bene
ragazzuoli per me possiamo concludere
che è stato è fichissimo come gioco però
secondo me manca una componente
essenziale che sono i livelli degli
utenti cioè secondo me se il suo gioco
tu puoi mettere le rampe a caso quindi
ti fai percorsi dove di scendi tipo così
tipo non così così vai giù di bestia poi
prendi una rampa ti fai 800 giri
quello sarebbe finissimo quindi ragazzi
bravi che sia piaciuto cosa non mi piace
per i servizi di skype e scegliamo e
vabbè ci vediamo non proseguito dai
ragazzi
[Musica]
no